ACTUALLY THERE WAS AN ELECTRICAL
FIRE THAT STARTED.
YOU SEE IT THERE.
THAT IS THE REASON WHY THEY
FIRST DECIDED TO EVACUATE.
THOSE SPECIFIC SECTIONS.
ONCE THEY GOT THOSE
THE CONCOURSE AND NOW THEY'RE
TESTING THE IN ARENA MIC.
>> HERE IS HERBIE COULDN'TS.
>> AT THIS TIME, BY ORDER OF
THE FIRE CHIEF, WE'RE BEING
ASKED TO SLOWLY AND CALMLY
EVACUATE THE BUILDING.
THERE IS NO THREAT.
--  THERE IS NO THREAT TO
PUBLIC SAFETY.
I'D LIKE TO REPEAT.
THERE IS NO THREAT TO PUBLIC
SAFETY.
THE GAME HAS BEEN SUSPENDED, AND
WE NEED TO ASK YOU TO PLEASE, IN
AN ORDERLY AND CALM MANNER,
EVACUATE SCOTIABANK ARENA.
>> Matt: SO THE RAPTORS LEADING
66-38, YOU HEARD FROM THE PUBLIC
ADDRESS ANNOUNCER, HE ANNOUNCED
THE GAME IS BEING SUSPENDED.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT MEANS
EVERYONE IS GOING TO LEAVE THE
BUILDING AND THEN AT SOME POINT
BE ABLE TO COME IN, IF THEY'RE
ABLE TO HANDLE THE CURRENT
SITUATION.
WE WILL SEE.
LET'S SEND IT NOW UP TO KAYLA
GREY.
KAYLA.
>> Kayla: THANKS, MATT,
OBVIOUSLY THE SITUATION IS
FLUID.
WHERE WE NORMALLY ASSIST, WE
ASSUME THERE WAS A FIRE IN A
SPEAKER.
I WAS ABLE TO TALK AND GET
CLARIFICATION FROM ONE OF THE
FIREFIGHTERS HERE, AND THE
REASON BHIE EVERYONE IS ASKED TO
EVACUATE IS PAUSE THE SPEAKER IS
IN A PARTICULAR SPOT, SOMEONE
MIGHT HAVE TO DECENT TO PUT IT
OUT.
IF IT CONTINUES TO GET ENGULFED,
SOMETHING MIGHT FALL, SOMETHING
MIGHT HAPPEN, SOMEONE MIGHT BE
HIT.
THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE
TAKING ALL NECESSARY PRECAUTIONS
FOR SAFETY, GUYS.
>> Matt: THANK YOU, KAYLA.
AND OBVIOUSLY THE FOLKS HERE AT
THE ARENA MOVING OUT IN A VERY
ORDERLY FASHION, AND OBVIOUSLY
AS A PRECAUTIONARY MEASURE RIGHT
NOW, THE TORONTO FIRE DEPARTMENT
HAS MADE THE DECISION TO SUSPEND
THE GAME AT THIS STAGE.
>> Jack: SO JUST TALKING TO
JENN QUINN, APPRECIATE HER
COMING OVER AND THE --  WE'RE
BEING TOLD AT THIS TIME -- SO
THERE WAS A SMALL ELECTRICAL
FIRE.
>> Jack: YUP.
>> Matt: THAT WAS IN A SPEAKER,
AND SO THEY WERE CONCERNED,
OBVIOUSLY, THAT THE SPEAKER --
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY THE PA
SYSTEM WAS SHUT DOWN FOR A TIME
BEING, THEY WERE CONCERNED,
OBVIOUSLY, THAT IT COULD FALL.
AND SO THEY'RE NOW TRYING TO
DECIPHER EXACTLY -- IT'S
SUSPENDED NOW, THE GAME.
DOES THAT MEAN THAT IT'S
SUSPENDED TO A LATER DATE?
LATER TIME?
OR WILL THEY PLAY IT --
>> Jack: RESUME IT LATER ON?
AND IT'S AN ON GOING --
>> Matt: IT'S A VERY FLUID
SITUATION.
OBVIOUSLY WE APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY JUST TAKING THEIR
TIME, YOU KNOW, GETTING OUT.
IT ISN'T SOMETHING, AS FAR AS
PANIC.
>> Jack: NO, NOT AT ALL.
>> Matt: IT'S EVERYONE DO WHAT
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO DO.
THEY ARE -- YOU CAN SEE THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT THERE, ABOVE THAT
SECTION 104, 106 AREA.
>> Jack: CLEARLY IT'S A
DIFFICULT SPOT TO GOT TO.
SO IT'S GOING TO TAKE SOME MAN
POWER AND SOME WORK TO GET UP
THERE AND ASSESS THE SITUATION
DIRECTLY.
SO THE IN HOUSE SECURITY, AS
WELL AS OBVIOUSLY THE TORONTO
FIRE DEPARTMENT IN THE MIDST OF
ASSESSING THIS RIGHT NOW.
>> Matt: AND SO THAT'S WHY THEY
BEGAN WITH THAT SECTION, RIGHT?
THE CONCERN THERE, ABOUT THAT
SPEAKER, UNDERSTANDABLY SO.
YOU DO SEE FANS MAKING THEIR WAY
OUT ON TO THE CONCOURSE LEVEL.
SOME FANS STILL LINGERING ABOUT,
OBVIOUSLY, WITH THAT ENTIRE
SECTION IS NOW ESSENTIALLY
EMPTY, WHERE THEY WANTED IT TO
BE EMPTY, AND THE TORONTO
RAPTORS OBVIOUSLY UNFORTUNATE
BECAUSE THEY GOT OFF TO SUCH A
GREAT START, JACK, AND PLAYING
AT A VERY HIGH LEVEL AND SO NOW
THEY'RE BACK IN THE LOCKER ROOM,
AWAITING WORD, JUST LIKE WE ARE,
INDIANA ALSO AWAITING WORD, JUST
LUKE WE ARE AS WELL.
>> Jack: I'D LIKE TO SAY ONE
THING, THANK GOD IT HAPPENED
WITH 4:05 REMAINING IN THE
SECOND QUARTER, WHERE MOSTLY
EVERYBODY IS IN THEIR SEATS,
YOU'RE ABLE TO MAKE THE
ANNOUNCEMENT AND GET EVERYONE
OUT IN AN ORDERLY FASHION.
IF IT'S AT HALF TIME, SOMETIMES
THE LIGHTS GO DOWN, AND IT
BECOMES A MUCH MORE DIFFICULT
SITUATION TO HANDLE.
SO I'M REALLY IMPRESSED WITH HOW
GREAT ALL THE FANS ARE IN TERMS
OF MOVING OUT IN AN ORDERLY
FASHION AND JUST TRYING THEIR
BEST TO ASSESS THE SITUATION.
BUT EVERYTHING IS CALM.
EVERYTHING IS OKAY HERE.
AND RIGHT NOW, THE RAPTORS JUST
TRYING TO -- THE OFFICIALS JUST
TRYING TO GET THINGS UNDER
CONTROL HERE.
BUT, HEY, GAME WAS EXCITING.
RAPTORS PLAYED VERY, VERY WELL
TO THIS POINT.
AND IN TERMS OF THE
WORD "SUSPEND", I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THAT MEANS.
>> Matt: I JUST SAW VIDEO
FOOTAGE VIA PHONE THAT SOMEONE
TOOK OF THE SPEAKER.
SO YOU CAN SEE SOME SPARKS
THERE, AND OBVIOUSLY DOING THE
RIGHT THING IN TAKING ALL THE
PRECAUTIONS NECESSARY.
WE HOPE OBVIOUSLY TO BE PLAYING
BASKETBALL AGAIN THIS EVENING.
HOWEVER, UNDERSTANDABLE THAT THE
PRECAUTIONS ARE BEING TAKEN
HERE.
WE ARE GOING TO REMAIN HERE
THROUGHOUT THE COURSE OF THE
EVENING UNTIL FURTHER NOTICE,
AND HOPEFULLY WE'LL RESUME
BASKETBALL AT SOME POINT THIS
EVENING.
BUT AS OF RIGHT NOW, WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO A COMMERCIAL BREAK, AND
THEN WE'LL COME BACK RIGHT AFTER
THESE